not as funny as Rob as witty as Mary or
as lovely to listen to as Alex near
house but I am back in then the less not
to worry as your ultimate host will be
back regularly but for now you've got me
so here's the things that mattered in
gaming today Nintendo has revealed that
the Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
will need to sell over two million units
to be profitable now this is a Zelda
game so that's not entirely out of the
realm of possibility but it is a bloody
big number the Sega was revealed by
Shigeru Miyamoto during a shareholder
meeting in Japan which was live blog by
Twitter use their end style and
translated by cheese meister breath of
the wild will launch on both the Wii U
and Nintendo z-- next gaming platform
codenamed NX Miyamoto added that over
the course of its five year development
cycle 300 people have worked on the game
and it currently has a development staff
of 100 people Miyamoto also said that
the NX wasn't shown at e3 because
Nintendo was worried about imitators if
they release info about the console too
early as it is we know almost nothing
about the box but you can check out a
whole host of current rumors in our
stories on games butts PlayStation 4
users patiently waiting for fallout 4
months to arrive we'll probably need to
sit tight a little longer but there's
the twister Twitter to explain that the
ps4 mods beta has been delayed and they
will be updating people on its status
when possible if the beta is suffering a
delay there's a good chance the public
release will to a week and a half ago
Bethesda acknowledged that they were
having some pretty big problems with the
fallout 4 mods program on ps4 including
those that could lead to memory and
performance issues fallout 4 mods
arrived on Xbox one in May the mods are
created on PC and are then published to
Bethesda dotnet where console players
can download and install go finally sony
appears to have no plans to connect the
ps4 and PC in the same way
Microsoft you've done with the Xbox one
Microsoft recently revealed their play
anywhere program where games purchased
on either the Xbox one or PC can be
played across both platforms at no extra
cost
much like Sony's cross my feature with
certain titles over ps4 ps3 and Vita
during Sony's investor day so many
interactive entertainment President
Andrew house was asked whether Sony plan
to follow in Microsoft's footsteps by
implementing a similar platform
unification strategy with PC he replied
there was a big emphasis from the folks
at Microsoft on Xbox and PC cross-play
it remains to be seen whether there is
latent large consumer demand for that we
don't see it as really affecting or
prompting any change in our thought
process or strategy we shall let me know
down in that comment box what you cared
about today and stopped by GameSpot for
stories on PlayStation VR and
battlefield one and we'll catch you
again tomorrow